l'insertion professionnelle des
réunionnais fait partie des principales
missions du département en 2014
elle a collecté durée à financer les
allocations de solidarité à hauteur de
38,5 millions d'euros pour mener une
politique efficace et cohérente
le département mise sur l'insertion des
publics en difficulté tout en agissant
sur l'économie dans les domaines du
service à la personne ou du tourisme
mais aussi à travers le challenge des
créateurs l'insertion par l'économie est
favorisée à l'antre-2 daisy s'occupe de
sa maman atteinte d'alzheimer depuis
deux ans une aide à plein temps facilité
par le versement de la paix a comme je
ne savais pas quoi faire quand j'ai
écrit au conseil général j'ai demandé de
me conseiller et ils m'ont fait un
dossier en disant voilà que je pouvais
aider prendre ma mère y recevoir un
petit peu d'appétit pour m'occuper
d'elle je pense que oui un jour je
pourrai l'homme est renvoyé mais ce
serait vraiment la france parce que bien
sûr moyen en suis à lyon tombe on n a
fait qu il voit pas elle est juste à
côté c'est sa robe baie n'est pas loin
pour arriver noir en matière de tourisme
la filière bois de goyavier est un
exemple d'insertion par l'économie en
plein développement
elle a tous les atouts nécessaires pour
séduire les touristes venus se mettre au
vert dans les jardins du vvf à
l'ermitage les agents installe en ce
moment des cabanes perchées réalisé à
partir de bois pays
une première qui répond à une véritable
demande
oui la demande elle est là les gens qui
passent ils peuvent pas s'empêcher de
tourner la tête et de venir poser des
questions et de demander quel prix
combien ça coûte une cabane comme ça et
je veux dire un prix comme ça en train
de les lier à 5000 euros et une cabane
perchée ou une cabane père mère à 50000
dos 50 mètres carrés enfin à travers le
challenge des créateurs un coup de pouce
est apportée aux personnes en recherche
d'emploi qui ont créé leur entreprise
marie danielle mercat à la tête des
éditions la plume et le parchemin est
une des lauréates 2014 et une période où
le chômage pendant laquelle j'étais
hauteur en fait j'ai écrit plusieurs
livres et j'ai rencontré votre hauteur
dans le même cas et du couvain genevois
volume et crée son propre projet là et
puis créer mon propre emploi aussi alors
le challenge des créateurs n'en sortais
mon reconnaissance énorme donc dans la
reprise de l'assertion pour moi c'est le
plus beau à serait tout ce combat que
j'ai mené six enfants jpy toujours à
courir derrière tout le monde est là
maintenant on appelle pour me dire rien
faire nous entier
et de commenter été terrassé moment
énorme voilà ça va bien j'espère
permettre de développer tout ce que tout
se professionnalise et les publics en
recherche d'emploi agir sur l'économie
et développer des filières d'avenir tels
sont les objectifs poursuivis par le
département grâce à l'insertion par
l'économie